so first of all i love this movie the
first 30 minutes it feels like this cute
rom-com and then in an instant
everything changes and it goes so dark
uh sebastian you know what i love about
your characters is you feel like patrick
bateman vibes meets hannah blechter were
you hesitant at all to take on such a
twisted character
well uh
from numerous reasons but one of them
being what you just mentioned is that
we've seen sort of characters in this
kind of world that that have been done
by unbelievable actors and and so it was
a bit of kind of what what
what is different about this or what
what could be different and i think i
think for me it was just the the
blend of humor with horror that that the
movie was sort of
had in this it had in the script and and
that mimi so
um
brilliantly kind of brought to the
screen
um and and and that genuine connection
like at the beginning of the movie like
you said it starts off in a certain way
and and i feel like if you don't know
anything about the movie you're
definitely invested and then the whole
thing kind of reveals itself so
yeah i hadn't actually watched a trailer
before watching the movie so the whole
thing was a huge surprise to me which
was
really awesome and terrifying um i want
to know who in your life has had the
best reaction to watching you in this in
this movie
i know i know my my
mother
texted me after the trailer saying
did you
did you really and she'll always be like
sebastian
did you really have to uh to do this uh
this thing
i was like it's acting it's you know
anyway so i don't know if my mom's going
to watch it but what are you doing i'm
going to watch it has you have your
parents both my parents have watched it
like four times oh wow
i really really liked it i mean my mom
is like massively squeamish when it
comes to um she can't watch people like
eat anything on food sorry on tv
any food on tv like even in like a
master chef like she struggles
like i don't know she she read the
script too and she she couldn't get
through it because she was so squeamish
they really liked the film like really
loved the film so yeah they've seen it
like four times but i'm not surprised
the movie's so good like my sister and i
were both watching it and our mouths are
open the whole time we were just like we
just couldn't believe what was happening
next but i loved your character so much
i feel like a lot of the times when it
comes to horror films you know you're
kind of yelling at the tv when
characters make certain decisions and
especially towards the end your
character's so refreshing did you feel
that way
i'm really glad you thought that well i
think yeah i think what's really cool
about
noah is that she yeah through this
experience she finds this sort of
strength within her that she didn't know
she had and like you know i i liked that
at times she was unreadable and i wanted
to play that like i wanted to play that
you don't know what's going through her
head um and that she is sort of
yeah um very much i guess just like
trying to come up with a plan and um and
yeah i mean i i think it was really
refreshing too that you know ultimately
the women sort of save each other and
save themselves it's not like um someone
comes to rescue them so i really liked
that aspect of it too yeah that's what i
loved about it too and i got the rap but
sebastian i read that you know you've
heard about this script but it wasn't
until daisy got attached that then you
really pushed to get on this is that
true
it is true because i'd watch normal
people on the pandemic like everybody
else and and i was so blown away with
her performance and just the themes of
the of that show and then i just thought
her
coming on i just knew immediately the
whole project got very grounded in in a
very
real sort of authentic way and i thought
as a result
you know noah was going to be a very
sort of smart kind of the way i'd
envision it you know
world weary kind of kind of um character
thanks to daisy playing her and then and
then that elevated steve for me because
then it made it meant he had to
he had to be strong enough or or
manipulative enough or believable enough
to kind of for her to kind of connect so
um yeah it was it was then i thought oh
this is going to be a really interesting
chess chess match kind of
story in a way what it turned out to be
yeah it definitely was congrats on on
this this is a really really good and i
woke up this morning thinking about i
watched it last night and i'm still
thinking about it so good job
thank you thank you
you